Here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to start out by keeping track of the results in a list,
which is initially the empty list.
I'm keeping track of the max value.
Initially we don't have any.
Now, the key function, I'm either going to use the key function
you provided me, or if you didn't,
I'm going to use the function that just maps
an argument to itself, and that's for this notation here.
Lambda x maps to x means
the function that maps the function to itself.
And then I'm going to go through the iterable.
For each x, I come up with an x value, which I get
by applying the key, and if the x value
is greater than the max value so far,
or if I don't have a result yet at all,
and that would be the case if I'm at the first element of the iterable,
then I want to create the result to be
this list of the single item x,
the value of the first one that I've looked at,
and I want to set the max value to be equal to that x value.
If it's a tie, then I just want to append x onto the list of results
that I've been building up all along.
And then at the end, I want to return the result.
Now, of course, I should write tests for this as well
just as I always did, and now that I have allmax
and I have my new version of poker,
I've also got to write a new documentation string here.
I've written a new documentation string for poker
to say that it's returning a list of the winning hands
rather than a single winning hand.
I have the definition terms of allmax.
I should write more tests for allmax.
I should go back and change the tests for poker
so that instead of returning a single hand,
they return a list of the single hand for the tests I have so far.
And then I should also add some more tests where there are some ties
and make sure that it handles that properly.
Once I've done that, it looks like I'm done.